aujourd'hui laurence but retombe est à
l'honneur cette forêt des
cantons-de-l'est bienvenue tout le monde
merci d'être là c'est des randonnées ou
jamais les gens découvrir en forêt
qu'est-ce qui pourrait manger mais aussi
qu est ce que vous pourriez cueillir
même en plein hiver pour l'un et chez
vous faire des tisanes des soupes faire
mijoter la viande et les épées s'en
ferait donc c'est un peu ça alors on se
promène au key puis par la suite on
revient qui ont puisé mon ensemble la
forêt et que j'ai hâte de voir toute la
bande en ce cas le à nous offrir avec un
regard nouveau
je suis ici parce que je suis quand même
toujours leurs liens avec la cache têtu
et redetar tabou et l'activité débute en
écoutant en 100 ans
et en regardant la forêt une façon de
lui communiquer notre présence sous est
prêt on veut repartir
c'est sûr que l'hiver c'est pas
suffisant pour se nourrir que de ce même
que j'ose dire de façon historique les
gens plutôt aller cueillir en été et en
automne préparer leur nourriture pour
l'hiver pour avoir des réserves
puis c'était vraiment juste en cas de
dernier recours laurence est aussi
avocate elle côtoie beaucoup les
autochtones dans sa pratique
je découvre certaines relations à la
forêt l'occident différentes pâtes de ce
à quoi moi j'avais est habitué ma
passion c'est vraiment plus la forêt en
fait là devant nous on a cet arbre est
un véritable trésor
le sapin baumier comme la plupart des
conifères en fait
or beaucoup nutriments dans les
aiguilles du sapin vous allez avoir
beaucoup de vitamines c et marché les
aiguilles ça se mange aussi ses bons
savoir que vous pouvez les mettre en
infusion mais vous pouvez aussi les
manger tel quel laurence nous suggère de
mettre des aiguilles de sapins dans
notre bouteille d'eau
ce petit goût citronné fait en sorte que
ça va très bien à lui notamment avec des
plats de poisson
on n'est pas habitué de manger de notre
sapin pourtant mange romarin ça ça
ressemble un peu par contre attention à
lift du canada c'est un sapin toxiques
qui demeure petit pour ne pas le
confondre avec un autre conifères que y
est toujours sur des arbres matures où
c'est ce qui se mange sur elle le sapin
mais sur les autres conifères aussi on
veut regarder sur les corses vend des
espèces de petites vésicules puis ce
seront plus de sel puisse allah seul de
sapins elle est comestible
la première fois ces rames à ces
vésicules contiennent des sels minéraux
et des sucres la forêt a d'ailleurs
sauvé la vie de nombreux explorateurs et
collomb appelle dans notre histoire que
l'on a faites sont avec discours but
mais on se souvient peau dure mère de
pierre chevrier est aussi un amoureux de
la forêt qu'il fait découvrir aux
touristes de la baie james
parfois la scène avant se cristalliser
sur les troncs ça va le faire sur la
plupart des conifères donc là vous allez
vraiment voir des espèces de boule de
gomme un peu cristalline sur l'arbre ça
peut être des heures de plaisir on vient
récolter la gomme ça fait vraiment fait
comme une gomme à mâcher 5 devant tom
c'est donc on va couper cette branche de
toute façon on veut l'utiliser en titane
par la ccit jusqu'au tron qui est
vraiment plus dur c'est ce qu'on dit
dans le fond qui s'appelle les corses
interne cette partie lors on peut la
manger crus tels quels ou
traditionnellement si c'était sécher
puis reid
puis en poudre dans le fond avec un
marty ça faisait une farine 50 et
beaucoup d'amis dont qui est un seul
complexe
donc c'est vraiment une bonne source ou
sud d'énergie l'hiver en forêt autre que
les conifères
les corses interne dû être à grandes
feuilles du boulot et de l'érable sont
aussi comestibles pendant qu'on parle
des rames nos chances qu'on peut manger
dans l'érable les petites sa mort qui
tombe des érables excuses helicopters
est ce que ça contient des graines de
segré ne sont comme eux seuls les sa
mort ses fameux fruit de l'érable porte
des graines bourré de protéines
l'accueil est terminée non branches de
sapin vont servir pour la tisane les
grandes branches servent à la cuisson du
poisson apportée par laurence ça va être
une cuisson sur la braise pendant que ça
cuit les aiguilles drogba vont
légèrement brûlé la messe à se rendre
peu juste en haut puis toute la vapeur
tout les arts on m'en fait du sapin vous
venir un bib et le poisson si la braise
est vive
ce sera un petit 20 minutes d'attentes
avant la dégustation même durée pour les
légumes racines
assaisonner d'aiguilhe de sa patte sur
le feu
on prépare le pain traditionnel
autochtone la banique fait de farine
d'huile et d'eau ce qu'on peut ajouter
site de la farine à base des corses
interne puis le feu vous lavez séchez
comme ça on souhaite il faut le moudre
ça donne un petit goût qu un côté
sauvage qui est intéressant que ce soit
en bulu en tortillon sur un bâton et
même à la maison dans un poêlon la
banique à plusieurs techniques de
cuisson
ça c'est la cuisson convenable oui c'est
une bonne puissance et on environ 10
minutes mais c'est toujours mieux de la
tester donc on peut prendre un petit
bout à toi l'honneur ça semble bien
parfait
parfait à qui va être longue je vous
invitais si vous avez envie à venir
goûter donc notre saumon et nos légumes
en plein hiver c sas essentiellement les
conifères c'est quand même nos meilleurs
amis khalifa et le boulot puis vous
n'êtes pas mal sur talons retrouver
n'importe où
[Musique]